To many, sugarcane might just look like
a tall grassy plant growing in the
fields. But for much of the world, it's
so much more. It's brown gold, the
lifeblood of a multi-billion dollar
industry that fuels global economies,
supports millions of farmers, and
produces everything from sweet treats to
bofuels. But have you ever wondered how
this humble stock transforms into the
pure white crystals sitting in your
kitchen?
[Music]
The journey begins in endless fields
where sugarcane stretches toward the
blazing sun. Thanks to cuttingedge
harvesting machines built specifically
for this crop, thick, juicy stalks are
cut close to the ground, cleaned, and
loaded for the next stage of their
transformation.
[Music]
From the field, the cane is transported
to high-tech factories where not a
single part goes to waste. Under the
watchful eyes of skilled engineers and
guided by precision automation, the cane
is crushed, filtered, boiled, and spun
until it becomes sparkling white sugar.
But the story doesn't end there. The
byproducts like fibrous bags are turned
into green energy in sustainable
building materials while nutrient-rich
molasses is repurposed into animal feed
or fermented into alcohol. Today on
Modern Agri machines, we'll take you
inside some of the world's most advanced
sugar production facilities to uncover
the full story behind this incredibly
versatile crop. From the harvest to the
final grain, you'll discover how modern
agricultural machines are
revolutionizing every step of the
sugarcane industry, maximizing
efficiency, minimizing waste, and
pushing toward a more sustainable
future. So, sit back, relax, and get
ready to dive into the sweet and
mechanical journey. Let's get started.
[Music]
Before we can harvest those tall, juicy
stalks of sugar cane, everything starts
with planting. And these days, it's no
longer backbreaking labor with rusty
tools. In today's techdriven fields,
powerful machines take over. Precise,
efficient, and immune to the heat.
Welcome to mechanized sugarce planting.
Instead of chopping and planting by
hand, farmers now load seed canes into a
hopper, and the machine does the rest.
Cutting stalks to choice, placing them
into furrows, covering with soil, and
adding fertilizer, all in one seamless
pass. Like a Swiss watch on wheels,
modern planters ensure every segment is
perfectly spaced and placed for optimal
growth. The result, bigger yields, less
labor, and no more scorching days in the
sun. And don't think these machines are
clunky beasts. They're built to handle
all kinds of terrain, from flat lands to
hilly fields, with some even using GPS
and soil sensors to adjust planting
depth in real time. It's smart farming
straight out of a sci-fi film. With
speeds of tens of thousands of stalks
per hour, these machines are reshaping
the sugar industry from the ground up.
And as advanced as they are, the mission
remains simple. Help each cutting grow
into a strong, healthy cane. Stick with
modern agri machines and we'll show you
exactly how the sweet story begins.
[Music]
If the stage of planting sugarcane is
the gentle prelude to the symphony
called sweetness, then harvesting is the
dynamic climax where the mechanical
warriors step onto the stage with
roaring sounds, continuous movements of
steel arms and sugar cane flying like
[Music]
fireworks. Welcome to the sugarcane
harvesting process with Modern
Machinery, where the entire field shakes
to the rhythm of steel, oil, and
high-tech innovation. In the past,
sugarcane harvesting was a laborious,
time-consuming task that required
immense effort. Dozens of workers had to
wade through sugarcane fields, chopping
down each stock with knives, bundling
them together, and dragging them to
bullet carts under the blazing sun and
sometimes swarmed by mosquitoes. But
those days are long gone.
[Applause]
[Music]
Now, with just a single sugarcane
harvester, you can do the work of an
entire army. Faster, cleaner, and with
incredible precision. Modern sugarcane
harvesters look like extraterrestrial
robots. Tall, versatile, and always
hungry for sugarcane. When operating,
the machine glides smoothly between the
sugarcane rows. Its spinning blades
quickly cutting the stalks near the base
without damaging the roots, allowing the
plant to regenerate for the next season.
Above, an automatic conveyor system
pulls the sugar cane into the machine's
body like it's swallowing spaghetti,
then neatly cuts it into standardized
sections, perfect for trucks and
pressing machines. The leaves and tops,
parts that aren't rich in sugar, are
immediately separated and returned to
the field as a natural cover, keeping
the soil moist and replenishing
nutrients. Fast, neat, clean, and
eco-friendly. This is sugarcane
harvesting in the new generation.
Moreover, advanced machines are equipped
with GPS, moisture sensors, yield
analysis computers, and even
surveillance cameras. This helps
operators know exactly where they are in
the field, which area has mature sugar
cane, and where to adjust cutting
speeds. It's like controlling a mobile
command center, not just a simple
machine. In countries like Brazil,
Thailand, or India, these harvesters are
specially designed to suit the terrain
of each region. There are four-wheel
machines for large planes, compact
machines for navigating between small
field borders, and even ones that can
climb hills. Because with sugar cane,
wherever there's sun and soil, it's a
place to harvest. And did you know an
average harvester can process more than
100 tons of sugar cane per day, the
equivalent of dozens of manual laborers?
Not only does this save costs, but it
also reduces the pressure on farmers,
increases regional productivity, and
most importantly ensures the freshness
of the sugar cane is preserved until
it's sent to the factory. Sugar cane
harvesting videos are always the most
popular on the PJ Modern Agri machines
channel because they're not just
visually stunning, but also inspiring.
There's something special about watching
the entire field of sugarcane move. Each
row falls steadily. The stalks fly into
the containers while the leaves gently
fall to the ground like summer snow. The
entire process showcases not only the
power of machinery, but also the
advancement of modern agriculture where
humans and machines work together
creating a closed loop system,
efficient, clean, and extremely smart.
And if you're wondering what happens to
the sugar cane after it's cut, then get
ready for the next stage in the journey.
Transporting it to the factory,
extracting the juice, boiling the sugar,
and refining it into sparkling sugar
crystals. But that's a story for another
episode. For now, just admire that
machine gliding through the fields like
a steel dragon, taking down each sugar
cane clump in perfect mechanical rhythm.
This is the beauty of technology in
agriculture where every drop of sweat
from the farmer is supported by
machinery to make it sweeter, more
precise, and more deserving than ever
before.
[Music]
After leaving the field in the arms of
modern harvesters, sugar cane stalks
begin a new journey from plant to white
gold. Loaded onto specialized trucks,
they race along village roads towards
sugar refineries.
[Music]
Time is sugar. Freshly cut cane must be
processed quickly to preserve its
sweetness. At the factory, stalks roll
onto massive conveyor belts leading into
powerful steel rollers that crush them
and extract the juice. The sound of
metal and liquid fills the air, a
mechanical symphony of sweetness.
[Music]
[Applause]
But this raw juice isn't ready yet. It
must pass through filters and settling
tanks to remove mud, fibers, and
impurities. Next comes the most magical
stage, boiling. Inside giant vats, the
juice is heated until it thickens into
syrup, then crystallizes into sugar.
Every step, temperature, timing,
stirring is tightly controlled by
automated systems while engineers
monitor from control rooms. Once
crystallized, the mix enters a
centrifuge, spinning rapidly to separate
molasses from sugar. The molasses goes
on to make rum or feed while the sugar
is dried and cooled into snowy white
crystals, ready for the world. But
nothing is wasted. The gas becomes
biomass fuel, paper, even furniture.
Steam and waste water are treated and
reused, creating a clean, circular
system. A modern model of zerowaste
agriculture. So next time you see a
spoonful of sugar, remember the
incredible journey behind it. From sunny
fields to roaring machines, from boiling
vats to sparkling crystals. And here at
Modern Aggra Machines, we bring you
every sweet moment.
[Music]
think sugarce bag gas is just lifeless
waste after juicing? Not at all. In
modern agriculture, beasi is a green
treasure. A raw material reborn into
countless useful forms. One major use,
organic fertilizer. When dried and
fermented with probiotics or organic
waste, bagas becomes nutrient-rich humus
packed with potassium, fiber, and
beneficial microbes. It nurtures healthy
crops, improves soil, retains moisture,
and prevents erosion, continuing the
sugar cane's life cycle right back into
the field. But its journey doesn't end
there. Be gas is also turned into
biodegradable paper, plates, and food
containers. That sturdy box holding your
sticky rice, likely compressed bags.
It's a smart, eco-friendly alternative
to plastic. Now exported globally by
countries like India, Brazil, and
Vietnam. Even more of the gas is used to
make biochar, a special charcoal that
enriches soil, locks away carbon, and
supports sustainable farming. Clearly,
nothing from sugarcane is wasted. From
sweet juice to smart reuse, this plant
helps build a cleaner, greener future.
And all of this, you're discovering it
with us right here at Modern Agri
Machines. Stay tuned. There's so much
more to
[Music]
come. Finally, the journey from
sugarcane in the field to the pristine
white sugar crystals has come to an end.
It is a long journey but one filled with
wonder where each step in the production
chain is elevated by modern technology
from the powerful harvesters to the
sophisticated production lines. Looking
back we can appreciate the intricacy of
every process from preserving the
freshness of the sugarcane to maximizing
the use of byproducts and even
protecting the environment through air
and wastewater treatment systems. It's
not just about creating an everyday
product we're familiar with. Sugar is a
vibrant testament to the collaboration
between the power of nature and human
ingenuity. Modern technologies not only
reduce labor, but also increase
productivity, protect resources, and
deliver sustainable economic value. Each
sugar crystal, though small, represents
the tireless labor and brilliance of
scientific innovations. In it, we see
not only material value, but also a
story of transformation, a reminder that
humans never cease to innovate. improve
and enhance the quality of life. If you
are someone who appreciates creativity
in agriculture, this journey is an
endless source of inspiration, a
reminder of the power of technology and
the skill in mastering natural
resources. Thank you for joining us on
this journey.
[Music]